What is MERS and is it going to kill me?
Middle East Respiratory Syndrome, or MERS,
is a viral respiratory illness that is relatively
new to humans.
It was first reported in Saudi Arabia in 2012
and is commonly localized to the Arabian Peninsula,
however it has since spread to several other
countries, including the United States, France,
and most recently South Korea.
MERS like SARS, is a coronavirus that typically
presents as a cold and upper respiratory infection
including fever, cough, and shortness of breath.
MERS is dangerous because it is more severe
than a common cold, and can lead to gastrointestinal
symptoms and kidney failure.
As with all infections, children, seniors,
and people with compromised immune systems
or pre-existing medical conditions are more
likely to contract MERS.
Unfortunately, this list includes mostly the
type of people found in hospitals, making
hospitalization in an area experiencing an
outbreak of MERS a huge risk-factor for infection.
Other risk factors include direct interaction
with an infected person, travel to the Arabian
peninsula or interaction with a camel.
Yep, camel.
Based on information from the US Center for
Disease Control, the incubation period, or
time between exposure to MERS and the appearance
of symptoms, is usually about 5 or 6 days,
but can be anywhere from 2-14 days.
Patient zero in the recent South Korea outbreak
was a man who traveled to countries in the
Middle East and did not exhibit any symptoms
on his return flight to Korea.
He became sick a week later.
MERS is not thought to be easily transmitted
between humans, that is why the extent of
the South Korean outbreak, with three deaths
and the number of people in quarantine at
1600 and climbing, is confusing to scientists.
Actually, scientists are confused by a lot
more than that, because we don’t actually
know how the disease spreads.
SARS, its sister disease, is communicated
via virus laden droplets from a cough or sneeze
but it is possible that MERS is airborne like
measles which can linger in a room for hours.
To date, there have only been three reported
cases of MERS in the US, but worldwide MERS
has a mortality rate of 30% which is pretty
scary!
But if you’re a healthy adult who washes
their hands frequently, and actively avoids
contact with sick people and camels, you’ll
probably be okay.
And just be safe if you’re planning any
trips to South Korea or the Arabian peninsula
in the near future.
What scary disease are you most concerned
about?
Let us know in the comments down below, and
check out this video by Anthony to find out
more about the nature of viruses